there's that spiritual psychological  perspective of focusing so hard on  what's not right that you keep getting  more of it I just kind of quit a lot of  things Mindy Pals has been my doctor all  year she's been wonderful and I just  told her like I'm tired so we went into  a really minimalistic protocol where it  was like I'd only do like three things  three things because I was doing castor  oil packs at night coffee enemas in the  morning Red Light Pocket machine a  lymphatic drainage massages body work  with lymph with lymph movement I've  tried everything like it was just my  daily protocols on top of all the pills  was just extreme and I was exhausted and  so I've just simplified it so I  simplified it to a couple of things I  simplified it to uh Dr Ayman has a  supplement called happy saffron so I've  been taking that getting in the  hyperbaric chamber that one is my least  favorite because it's so boring but I do  that for one to two hours at a time when  I can